I
you
good morning if everyone will take their
seats please good morning
as a first order of business welcome to
our early morning panel 815 and I'm
Anita folsom most of you are here last
night but I'm the director of the free
market forum if you have a cell phone or
anything else with an alarm please turn
that off right now that would be very
helpful and let me say that we will have
our three presenters each give their
presentations and then at the end of
that we will have questions and answers
please wait for a microphone to come to
you that way your question can be heard
by everyone and we can also a videotape
your response so please wait for the
microphone and then here's one last of
piece of information about the question
and answer period and that is that this
forum is primarily for our invited
faculty so invite I want all of you
faculty members to be thinking about a
question you'd like to ask after after
the third presentation and if we can we
will try to work the invited faculty
members into the question and answer
period so if we see that you have a
question we'll try to get a microphone
to you if we can and for our other
guests please give our invited faculty
members an opportunity with their
questions too but we had terrific
questions last night with Peter Brooks I
don't think I've ever seen so many good
questions after one presentation good
all the way around and now on to our
first panel which is chaired by someone
I know Burton Folsom bird is a native of
Lincoln Nebraska he studied at center
college and Indiana University and his
PhD is from the University of Pittsburgh
he is taught at murray state university
Northwood University and currently holds
the Klein chair in history and
management at Hillsdale College he also
worked for several years at the Mackinac
Center for Public Policy and the Center
for the American
he's published six books including myth
of the robber barons now in its fifth
edition in which he explains the role of
market entrepreneurs and political
entrepreneurs which has been one of his
major contributions to economic history
his latest book is New Deal or raw deal
how FDR's economic legacy has damaged
America he also serves as senior
historian at the foundation for economic
education and writes a quarterly column
for fees publication the Fremen he's
written articles and dozens of papers
some of you may have seen him on the
Glenn Beck show or fox and friends or
his Bert's all-time favorite book TV on
c-span and on talk radio he is a
frequent guest of rusty humphries
michael medved and many others he and I
write for our blog at Burt Folsom calm
and we are working on co-authoring a
book together called FDR goes to war
that will be out in about a year please
welcome dr. Burton Folsom
thank you
Thank You Anita it's good to be here and
it's neat to have all those inside
contacts at the free market forum that I
have with Anita she she does a great job
and it's good to see all of you here and
we have a fine panel on health care and
what I'd like to do is introduce our
speakers and the first speaker who will
come up and talk with us this morning is
Thomas phillipson and Thomas is the
Daniel Levin professor of Public Policy
Studies at the University of Chicago he
is an associate member of the department
of economics and a former senior
lecturer at the law school his research
focuses on health economics and he
teaches microeconomics and health
economics he's also lectured at Yale
University and at the World Bank he is
currently serving his visiting scholar
at the American Enterprise Institute and
phillipson was born and raised in Sweden
where he obtained his undergraduate
degree in mathematics at Upsala
University he received his MA and PhD in
economics from the wharton school and
the university of pennsylvania
phillipson served in the second Bush
administration as the senior economic
advisor to the head of the Food and Drug
Administration and also as the senior
economic advisor to the head of the
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services he was a senior health care
advisor to John McCain during his 2008
presidential campaign he has appeared on
numerous television programs to discuss
health care and his articles on the
subject have been very influential and
so we'd like to welcome fillip his talk
on health care reform and innovation
philip thomas philipson
Thanks thanks for having me I'm going to
talk today about pharmaceuticals and
regulations as in the program i'm going
to talk more about medical innovation
and government care which pharmaceutical
is essential Pharmaceuticals is probably
the most aren't the intensive industry
we have in the u.s. about sixteen
percent of sales goes to research and
development and is one of several
industries heavily engaged in medical
innovation including devices biologics
and other medical products when
economists think about innovation in
healthcare where innovation generally
they think about how much innovators in
terms of promoting innovation they think
about how much innovators appropriate
their returns from their R&D investments
what I mean by that so think about my
favorite technology which is the ipod
and the ipod if it's sold four to two
hundred dollars let's say if you as a
customer were willing to pay let's say a
thousand dollars for an ipod we would
say that you as a customer if it's
selling a two hundred gain about eight
hundred dollars from buying the ipod if
your maximum willingness to pay was it
was a thousand dollars if it cost Apple
about hundred bucks to produce the ipod
we would say that the producers would
gain a hundred dollars so we call this
an economics producer and consumer
surplus and that's a very very important
concept because it basically divides how
much of the social value of the
innovation how much value beyond the
cost of producing it gets divided up
between innovators or producers or
consumers and generally when we talk
about medical innovations it's hard to
measure these consumer benefits but we
did work looking at the therapies for
HIV that came out in the mid-1990s
to try to estimate essentially what
share of the value of those therapies on
the market were captured or appropriated
by producers and found that about only
seven percent of the new therapies the
heart therapies that came out in 1996
which has extended lives of many HIV
patients were captured by innovators the
93 / the rest of the 90 of the value of
the products 93% once went to patients
who essentially benefited more in the
value of longevity beyond what they were
paying when when we look at medical care
and innovation and how government effect
the incentive to innovate economists
think about producers capturing that
innovation because being central and we
think about two forms of efficiency one
is static efficiency which is given a
technology given the new medicines for
HIV for example how much should actually
be consumed of a given technology once
it's been innovated and there we talk
about prices being too high being a
problem there's being an inefficiency if
these therapies are priced above costs
of the HIV therapy costs 20 gram per
year to consume some patients are
willing to pay maybe 5 grand a year or
can't afford it they're willing to pay 5
grand but it only costs maybe 1,000 to
produce it then we have an inefficient
situation because the patient's would
actually be willing to pay the therapy
to Purdue be produced but they're not
getting it they're willing to pay five
thousand and cost 1000 to produce but
they're not consuming it because the
price is twenty thousand that's an
inefficient situation and that basically
economists don't like they like
competition to bring down prices to cost
for that particular reason the reason we
don't have that of course is that we
want to stimulate innovation so we have
essentially our patents that give market
power to people who innovate and that's
in the name of what economists called
the namek efficiency that is to say if
we had no patents that is to say day one
when you market it when you launch the
drug on the
market generics were allowed to come in
and compete with that drug we wouldn't
have any drugs essentially so if if
these therapies were priced at cost
manufacturers cannot recoup the
estimated about 1 billion dollars it
takes to bring a drug to the market so
we we have a patent system which is kind
of a weird system it's something where
we reward innovators with something we
don't like which is monopoly power
monopoly in general we have antitrust
regulations against monopolies but we
have exemptions in antitrust laws for
research and development we essentially
award people with monopolies and
therefore we get attention many times in
medical care market between access that
is to say people can't afford it patent
protected therapies and RD which we need
this kind of patent protection for and
that's a constant sort of tension not
only medical care about other markets as
well patents patents are therefore
sometimes viewed as the second best way
of stimulating innovation because the
second best because we're rewarding it
with something we don't like now how
does health care reform effects these
innovation issues or basically the
rewards to innovation from manufacturers
well healthcare reform has as currently
being implemented has several sort of
general features one is the great
expansion of insurance coverage for poor
people who who otherwise could not
afford it that generally we believe is
will have a positive impact on
innovation because innovators now have
bigger markets for which people can buy
their products it it allocated away
money from Part C or Medicare Part C or
Medicare is basically a premium support
program Medicare Advantage where the
government supports your premium
purchases as opposed to get involved in
medical care which is part a and B
hospital and physician
Medicare where there's more centralized
pricing from Washington determining
incentives in the market the the
long-run effect of this the short-run
effect generally is positive for for
innovation in in these settings because
the quantity expansion of letting
basically expanding the market many
times in the short run outweigh the
compression on markups and how much they
can price above cost in these markets
however the long run experience has been
dismal if you look at a European Marcus
is sort of there where we're going in
the u.s. of having in the current reform
and european mart and european markets
there's been extensive compression of
incentives to innovate because
governments as single buyers have much
more market power and can compete that
or can basically push down prices for
innovation in the Europe European system
much more so than in a more private
system that we have in in the u.s. I was
asked to be an advisor to nice which is
sort of an agency in UK that decides on
in which technology is the the National
Health Service in the UK which pays for
most care in the UK which technology
they adopt and don't adopt and UK has a
very sort of a illustrative feature
which is sort of the intent of some of
the new reform efforts to for you for us
to kind of go in that direction where
they adopt technologies based on what's
what's so called cost-effectiveness
excuse me cost-effectiveness deal with
essentially how much are you paying for
each unit of Health if you want for a
medical product and nice more or you
came on now the country have sort of
institutionalized that payment system
that payment system is really just a
price control system in disguise in my
view basically you it's it's similar to
having a system where you're you have
the quality just a price of your house
that is to say let's say a price per
square foot and that you can't charge
higher than and a price per square foot
is very similar for what's called
cost-effectiveness which is costs for
health unit if you want so if you
restrict the price per square foot that
you can sell your house for them
presumably you have a total price that
you can sell above for the total size of
the house and that's essentially how the
UK system works now that's essentially
having a price control in conjunction
with a patent system which I have argued
many times it sort of schizophrenic
because the patent system is aimed at
manufacturers like I said being able to
capture the returns to or their the
returns to their R&D investments and a
price control essentially operates
exactly in the opposite direction by
pushing down those prices so
cost-effectiveness or more
cost-effective care cannot be the goal
we could get more cost-effective care in
the US by just eliminating the patent
system no one would be in in favor of
that so cost effective cares the wrong
gold the the right goal is to stimulate
a flow of innovation into the market and
in order to do that we need to have
people be able to recoup essentially the
larger and the investments that take
place before people market their product
now I was not very popular in the UK as
well when I mentioned that the UK is
about 3% of the world market for medical
care or medical products and that
therefore whatever they did in the UK
didn't really matter for innovation
because most manufacturers innovate for
the world in particular most
manufacturers innovate for the u.s. u.s.
which is only about five about a fifth
of world output is actually half roughly
of sales in medical innovation so most
manufacturers across the world innovate
to recoup their R&D expenses in the US
therefore the policies that we're
currently thinking about adopting to
mimic nice or mimic the UK system
in the in the US are very very dangerous
if they're implemented in the US because
in the u.s. there is a real innovation
trade-off in adopting these policies
given that US is supporting essentially
world innovation in medical our and deep
that's not true in the nice nice can do
pretty much anything and it wouldn't
affect our d in the world if the UK
adopts a similar system denies it will
have drastic effects on drying up rd not
only hurting the US by hurting a lot of
countries around the world those
countries it's not surprising why
they're doing what they're doing they
have is very strong incentive to control
prices in their countries sometimes
close to cost and because they
individually will not affect the flow of
products coming into the country because
they're not they're too small to affect
innovation together that's a big problem
if you're all European countries for
example act that way together and that's
about twenty five percent thirty percent
of the market and i will have
detrimental effects on rd that's the
direction that's the direction we
currently going in the US and that's the
direction which i think is very very
dangerous and i hope we will avoid
undertaken in the future i'll be happy
to take questions now or later depend on
how you want to start through later okay
thank you very much
Thank You Thomas we will have time for
questions at the end of the three
presentations today our second presenter
is going to be Sally pipes and Sally is
president and CEO of the Pacific
Research Institute which is based in San
Francisco before that she was assistant
director of the Fraser Institute in
Vancouver and Miss pipes addresses
national and international audiences on
health care issues she's appeared on
most of the major television talk shows
as an expert on health care and she's
written extensively for major newspapers
and journals and those are op eds by the
way well worth reading Sally served on
Rudy Giuliani's health care as his
health care advisor in his bid for the
Republican nomination in 2008 she has
authored numerous books including her
latest just published by Regnery in
August of 2010 entitled the truth about
Obamacare to answer the question does
government-run health care work please
welcome Sally pipes
thank you and I want to thank Bert and
Anita for inviting me and for putting
together a diverse panel we have a Swede
a Canadian and an American and I'm the
thorn between two roses so thank you
with a historic vote the 2500 page
patient protection and affordable care
act was signed into law on march 23rd we
just celebrated the six-month
anniversary last Thursday what I like to
say is understanding health care is
similar to unraveling an onion there are
many layers and many cheerful moments I
do think that everyone would agree that
the goal for America is affordable
accessible quality healthcare the
question is how do we achieve that goal
there are two competing visions for
healthcare reform and an achiever cyl
coverage one focuses on in my view
empowering doctors and patients and
encouraging innovation in new drugs
biologics and medical devices which is
what Thomas just talked about the other
however focuses on increasing the role
of government in our healthcare system
through increased taxes mandates
subsidies and controls on insurance
companies this is President Obama's
vision and what he achieved with the
Affordable Care Act it is what the late
Senator Ted Kennedy called Medicare for
all very few people in America and
certainly not in Canada where I'm from
realize that in America we don't have a
free market in health care fifty percent
of the healthcare system today is in the
hands of government through Medicare
Medicaid s chip and the VA the United
States last year spent seventeen point
three percent of its gross domestic
product or 2.5 trillion dollars on
healthcare 16 of our economy you hear
over and over again it is too much well
the country I'm from Canada we spend
about ten point four percent of our
domestic product on health care because
that's what the government determines
they can afford to spend on health care
because there is no private health care
in Canada except for what is illegal and
is a thriving business by the way but
Canada the government sets that global
budget as i said the budget that they
can afford but what does that mean for
canadians long waiting lists for care
the average weight from seeing a primary
care doc to getting treatment by a
specialist is 16.1 weeks that's four
months care is rationed or denied the
older you are the less likely you are to
get care and in fact my own mother died
five years ago from colon cancer when
she couldn't get a colonoscopy because
of her age you also have lack of access
to the latest technology the average
weight in America for getting a in
Canada for getting an MRI is four months
and that's why so many Canadians come to
the United States and pay out a pocket
for treatments and procedures so that's
what goes on in a country where
government has total control of your
health care the the Affordable Care Act
is not going to bend the cost curve in
this country down and as richard foster
chief actuary at Centers for Medicare
and Medicaid Services has said the u.s.
is going to spend three hundred and ten
billion dollars more under this new law
than if it had not been passed the
Affordable Care Act passed by the way I
note my timer isn't going off so I have
20 minutes from now till eternity I hope
when everyone's asleep the Affordable
Care Act passed without a single
Republican vote it is however noteworthy
that President Obama speaker Pelosi who
is from my San Francisco and Senator
Harry Reid Majority Leader did not care
about the views of the American people
on health care reform the Rasmussen poll
up into the vote showed that fifty-five
percent of Americans did not want
Obamacare and on September 20th my
birthday the poll showed
61 percent of Americans want the
Affordable Care Act repealed and I think
even more important an investor's
business daily poll has shown that
forty-five percent of practicing doctors
have said that they will seriously
consider giving up the practice of
medicine because of this new health care
law Americans do not want the federal
government to be in charge of their
health care system think about it think
about the Tea Party movement and what
that has done I've spoken at several tea
parties the Virginia and New Jersey
gubernatorial elections and of course
Scott Brown's election as the senator
from Massachusetts elected in January
President Obama's number one domestic
policy issue during a 2008 campaign
until passage of Obamacare on march
twenty third was health care reform he
said no one else no other president has
been able to accomplish that I was in
Phoenix the morning after the passage of
the son of the agreement on march 21st i
was in phoenix on the twenty-second
having given a speech and I was watching
on the monitor CNN and David Axelrod
said told Wolf Blitzer that Obama was
more excited about the passage of health
care reform than when he was elected
president so you can see just how
committed he was following passage of
the Affordable Care Act the GOP has been
talking about repeal and replace I
believe that they must keep to this
message until 2013 when if they take the
presidency and Congress the act can be
repealed people say over and over again
that it can't be repealed we'll think
back to nineteen eighty-nine Medicare
catastrophic it was repealed and Dan
Rostenkowski was run out of town so I
think it's very very important that we
keep up the fight to repeal and replace
this legislation there is a tenth
Amendment constitutional challenge
against the Department of Justice twenty
states and
the National Federation of Independent
Business are in one suit and the state
of Virginia has a second suit federal
judge Benson has just recently heard the
Florida case Judge Hudson in Virginia
upheld the legality of the case and in
the state of Missouri 71 percent of
voters in an initiative said that they
are against the individual mandate these
challenges though are over the
individual mandate Congress has the
constitutional authority to levy taxes
but it doesn't have the constitutional
authority to tell the American people
what it is that they must buy from the
private sector this is the reason that
President Obama first supported the the
the individual mandate under the
Commerce Clause but now he says its
attacks because he knows that's the only
way this will be upheld if it is deemed
to be attacks it is not going to be
possible to keep the costs of Obamacare
at nine hundred and forty billion
dollars over ten years as the
congressional budget office says and as
Obama had said so often during a
campaign I believe and many economists
agree that the cost of Obamacare from
2014 when most of the provisions come
into effect until 2024 will be about 2.4
trillion dollars a hundred and
fifty-nine new boards and commissions
are going to be established under this
law I'm going to spend a few minutes
talking about the main pillars of
Obamacare but I'm not going to talk
about the insurance controls because I'm
leaving that up to Scott but the
president's goal pillar number one
universal coverage and bending that cost
curve down the president's goal was
universal coverage under obamacare 34
million Americans are supposedly going
to become insured and 18 million of
those are going to be added to the roles
of Medicaid the program for our
low-income Americans the cost curve is
not going to go down and universal
coverage will not be achieved the CBO is
said by 29
23 million Americans will still be
uninsured out of today last week the
census bureau said that uninsured number
was 50 point seven million I think it's
interesting right now of that 50 point
seven million 14 million of them are
people who are already eligible for
Medicaid and s chip and haven't signed
up I ask you why I believe it's because
Medicaid patients cannot find doctors
because the reimbursement rates to dogs
are so low there are even lower than
what dogs who take on Medicare patients
are on the cost side the president said
over and over again we are going to bend
the cost curve down the average American
family will see their premiums go down
by twenty five hundred dollars well
guess what the CBO said the average
premium will go up by 21 hundred dollars
and the president continued to talk
about that until a couple of weeks ago
when he said adding 30 million people to
the roles of the insured is going to
bend the cost curve up well it's just
another example of you know telling the
American people a lie to get that health
care reform through pillar number two
Medicare and Medicaid Advantage programs
in 2011 Medicare Advantage the private
program for our seniors a quarter of
them are on Medicare Advantage they
really like it the government is going
to take 202 billion dollars out of
medicare advantage and richard Foster
has said it will take 11 million seniors
down to about six million seniors I was
doing a debate at harvard medical school
on tuesday night and on Tuesday morning
I read in The Boston Globe that Harvard
Pilgrim one of the largest insurers in
Massachusetts said at the end of the
year we will no longer be a lot of
offering insurance plans under Medicare
Advantage to 22,000 seniors in mass
Maine and New Hampshire the reason no
reimbursements from the federal
government this is going to spread
across the country traditional Medicare
is going to be cut by 575 billion
dollars over ten years well how are we
going to allow our seniors to have
access to health care and access to
doctors today one in three new Medicare
eligible patients is already having a
hard time finding a dog and Thomas
talked about research and development
innovation I believe the new head dr.
Don Berwick administrator of Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services who was
appointed by recess appointment is
really going to make a lot of changes
including comparative effectiveness
research making decisions about what
drugs and treatments are cost-effective
as compared to medically effective he's
a huge fan of the National Health
Service he calls it a seductress and a
global treasure so you know in Britain
750,000 Brits are on a waiting list just
to get into a national health service
hospital to get treatment in Canada 694
thousand Canadians are waiting to get a
horse into a hospital and have treatment
Medicare tax increases beginning in 2012
couples earning 250,000 a year
individuals earning 200,000 they are
going to face a point nine percent
increase in their medicare payroll tax
bringing it up to two point three five
percent and there's a whole new medicare
pay tax on unearned income
three-point-eight percent on the same
income groups so there will be this
three-point-eight percent tax on
dividends interest on the excess over
the sale that you can deduct from the
sale of your home pillar number three
new excise taxes on insurance companies
medical device companies and
pharmaceutical companies these new taxes
are going to have a very adverse effect
on R&D in our country pillar number four
state-run insurance exchanges beginning
in 2014 every state will have a
state-run insurance exchange where
people of that state can purchase their
insurance government though is going to
mandate what is in a pro
priate benefit package within those
exchanges including guaranteed-issue and
Community Rating meaning that insurers
will not be able to discriminate based
on one's medical history or charge a
different price based on the way you
live your life Kathleen Sebelius
Secretary of HHS has a tremendous amount
of power under this legislation just a
couple of weeks ago she said I'm going
to keep a list a list of what a list of
those insurers where she thinks that the
premium increases for their insurance
plans are too high she said if I believe
that they're too high those companies
that are on the list will not be able to
participate in these exchanges I will
have zero tolerance for misinformation
by insurance companies on what Obamacare
is going to do to their costs on july
first of this year temporary state-run
insurance exchanges were set up and the
feds put five billion dollars in well
richard foster again chief actuary at
CMS has said that money will be run out
either next year or for sure by 2012
pillar number five is the individual
mandate you can't have guaranteed-issue
and Community Rating without an
individual mandate I believe this is
going to cause the cost of insurance to
go up the 14 million young Invincibles
unfortunately I'm not a young invincible
anymore but we're going to make
conscious decisions not to buy insurance
because they are young and healthy and
probably nothing will happen to them
they want catastrophic insurance but
they're going to decide to pay the fine
in 2016 if they don't have insurance
that fine which is finally will be
capped in 2016 695 dollars or two point
five percent of income whichever is
greater how will you enforce the mandate
member Hillary Clinton told George
Stephanopoulos on ABC's this week well
George we could garnish wages well
that's not possible under Obamacare but
16,000 new IRS agent
are going to be hired in order to see
that people have insurance pillar number
six the employer mandate there is no
employer mandate but any firm with more
than 50 employees if any of their
employees receives a subsidy from the
federal government that company will
have to pay the fine of two thousand
dollars per employee for all employees I
think it's very likely a lot of firms
will decide to pay that two thousand
dollar fine rather than 5000 or 15,000
for a family up to provide insurance
remember the president said if you like
your health care plan and you like your
insurance nothing is going to change
well a lot is going to change the CMS
has said that 14 million people will
probably lose their employer-based
coverage as just as what I talked about
Doug holtz-eakin former head of the CBO
said 35 million the Lewin group said 114
million McDonald's just yesterday
announced that they probably won't be
able to provide the kind of insurance
that they were providing for their
30,000 employees so we are going to see
a lot of changes there is also a ten
percent tanning tax on small business
that went into effect on July first
there are 19 thousand small business
tanning salons in this country small
business is going to be hurt also the
1099 reporting requirement for anyone
who does business-to-business
transactions of six hundred dollars a
year or more it's going to have to file
that 1099 this is going to have a very
negative impact on small business there
is no public option or government-run
insurance plan in the Affordable Care
Act but mark my words it's not far away
lynn woolsey Democratic Democratic
congresswoman from Marin County already
introduced an amendment saying that she
that would put the public option back
into into the obamacare health care plan
and of course barney frank howard dean
they all love the idea of the pub
option so after a more of year after
more than a year of debate 58 speeches
President Obama said I believe that
Congress owes the American people a
final up or down vote on healthcare well
he did get his wish Nancy Pelosi said we
have to pass this bill so that we can
find out what's in it that was the
impetus for me writing the truth about
Obamacare and then Max Baucus a couple
of weeks ago senate finance chair said
well i don't have time to waste my time
reading the Affordable Care Act so I
said both of them should read my book
because it's a tenth of the size at 240
pages many economists myself included
believe ultimately there will be this
public option it will that government
insurance will be priced cheaper than
private insurers can offer insurance in
the exchanges demand for healthcare will
be higher than projected the cost will
increase beyond what government wants to
pay and we'll all be in a canadian-style
or national health style health care
system where there's a global budget a
budget the government can afford private
insurers will then be crowded out and we
will be on the way to ration care
Medicare for all the American people do
not want this but the president obama
president obama pelosi and reid have an
ideological vision about what America is
all about the Progressive Era is back it
looks like there will be some
interesting election results I think the
Republicans have got to stick to their
plan work in 2011 on repealing the class
act the 1099 form and starving off
funding to the Affordable Care Act for
Medicare Medicaid new program increases
Universal choice is the key to universal
coverage as I have said the president's
promise of achieving universal coverage
while reducing the cost of care is not
possible taxes will be up care will be
rationed and quality down Canadians come
to the United States where will we as
patients go and where will the best
Doc's go if we get this type of system
Danny Williams the the premier of
newfoundland in February when he was
told he needed a heart valve replacement
he went to Mount Sinai Hospital in Miami
Florida and when he came back the Press
said what were you thinking Danny
Williams said it's my health and it's my
choice we are on the road to serfdom
under Obamacare and we need to get on
the off ramp we need to repeal and
replace it is the only solution thank
you
Thank You Sally for those insights on
your book the truth about Obamacare and
I hope it's the best seller my only
concern is that with so many people
reading it they may decide they need
health care after having to get through
all of that but I appreciate your
insights into these issues our next
feature speakers Scott Harrington Scott
is the Allenby Miller professor at the
Wharton School of the University of
Pennsylvania where he teaches courses on
health care management and insurance and
risk management dr. Harrington received
his PhD from the University of Illinois
and he taught at the university of south
carolina before joining the wharton
faculty he serves as associate editor of
the journal of risk and insurance and is
on the board of advisors for catos
review of business and government he is
also adjunct scholar at the Cato
Institute and a visiting scholar at the
American Enterprise Institute he has
contributed to or co-authored numerous
texts on insurance and risk management
as we all look for ways to drive down
the costs of healthcare please welcome
Scott Harrington
Thank You Bert good morning everyone I
hit I have some connections to Michigan
I wrote a monograph if you will on your
automobile insurance system those of you
from Michigan in 1989 with the Mackinac
Center and I came up here to talk about
that monograph one very cold day in
december i also testified in front of
michigan state legislature a couple of
times on your automobile insurance
system so if you're happy with that
system I'm glad to say that that I
helped and if you're not happy with that
system I have to say that they didn't
listen to a lot of what I said but it is
very good to be back now my main theme
but I'm going to have to i'm going to
set it up is real ways to drive down
health care costs I have to see if I can
advance
I just press the button as we go forward
okay let's see if we can get our order
together now what do I want to go back
leave it there leave it there leaves
there go back look away all right what
I'm going to do is I'm going to give a
little brief background about the
problems that we have and talk about the
causes of those problems because if we
want to look towards solutions we have
to really understand the causes and part
of what I'll do with the causes is just
emphasize some of the points in Sally
made about the patient protection and
affordable care act now I try not to
call the patient protection and
affordable care act obamacare because it
has a pejorative connotation and I'm
from the Northeast and it's safer when I
speak if I don't use the term Obamacare
but I might slip occasionally otherwise
if I say ppaca then that's what I have
in mind now I'm not sure I can go back
but my first slide what I wanted to do
is to show you the annex orrible
increase in what the United States
spends on health care in relationship to
GDP and I also had some information
about the rate of growth in per capita
health expenditures over time but the
short version of the story is healthcare
expenditures have grown much more
rapidly than GDP for decades and as a
result more and more of total GDP is
represented by healthcare expenditures
and as Sally said we're up to about 17
and a half percent now who's running the
show here can I go back I can't go back
all right why did it go forward because
I want to have a go forward when I'm
ready to have it go forward okay
the next slide that you missed do not
move it until I put my hand up please
okay the next slide that you missed i
gave a a picture of health care
expenditures by country and people know
the basic result but it's really good to
see it visually because the united
states has a bar that you would have
seen that is much greater than all other
really industrialized developed
countries were about eight thousand
dollars per person now we're spending
the next closest country is under five
and it doesn't mean we spent too much
but we do spend too much it doesn't mean
the other countries spend too little but
many of them do spend too little so the
problem of high costs is real the
problem of cost growth is real and
another slide that you missed basically
showed how in the u.s. our rate of
growth is faster than in many other
countries even if you take into account
the phenomenon where countries that
don't spend much tend to grow their
healthcare expenditures more rapidly
than countries that spend a lot we're an
outlier on that dimension I can make
these slides available now the third
problem the second main problem is the
uninsured and Sally mentioned this a new
report came out just the week or two ago
there now are about 50 million people
uninsured that number has gone up quite
a bit during the recession and it's been
on a long run gradual increase what do
we know about the uninsured just a
little context to set up what the
president's plan and the Democrats plan
is done uninsured in this country have a
form of insurance they have a form of
insurance where they have access to
acute care if you have a problem you can
go to an emergency room as you know and
you are required to get stabilized or
get transferred this isn't free to you
necessarily it might be you might get a
bill if you can't pay the bill you may
have to take actions to step in the
personal bankruptcy so on a sense people
are insured for acute problems but they
hit get charged for it and they may have
to pay something for it the medical
community in the academic community have
paid a lot of attention looking at does
a lack of insurance harm or person's
health and longevity there are a lot of
strange numbers the
we'll be aunt bandied about I could
summarize the research by saying there's
some evidence that not having insurance
is bad for persons health there's some
evidence that it increases the
probability of dying at given ages but
yet the evidence is not that strong and
it's really not that convincing another
quick comment about the immature just to
set the stage and Sally mentioned one of
these these are not mutually exclusive
categories and you can see this but
about 10 million of the uninsured are
non-citizens we're not sure how many but
probably at least half of those are
unauthorized residents of the United
States about 15 or 14 million of the
uninsured are eligible for Medicaid but
they don't sign up so they are eligible
for free coverage but they don't take it
about 10 million people are eligible for
work related coverage either directly or
through a spouse but they do not elect
to be coverage and pay the workers
contribution not around 11,000 are 11
million of the uninsured have annual
incomes above 75 thousand dollars a year
and 20 million in total have annual
incomes above 50 thousand dollars a year
my colleague mark Pauly makes the point
that a lot of people do not have
insurance could afford to have some
basic amount of insurance and as we know
many of the uninsured are in fact young
and in fact 21 million of them were ages
18 to 34 next slide please
bear with me just a moment I'll get to
this particular picture in a minute the
third major problem is Medicare and
Medicare spending and I have to be
careful when I talk about this in
different audiences because people can
get the wrong point right now even with
a number based on excessively Rosie
assumptions the estimated Medicare
deficit over the next 75 years is about
twenty two trillion dollars twenty two
trillion dollars in present value the
United States total economy this year is
about 1.4 our 14 trillion dollars the
Medicare dusted to get a handle on it
and the number is actually too low if
you had 22 trillion dollars and you
could invest it at four or five percent
interest you could basically cover the
shortfall in Medicare spending over the
next 75 years and end up even now
clearly that's a number that just
boggles the mind the graph that I had
that we've skipped through showed the
projectory of actual federal spending on
Medicare the next few years it's not too
bad but then the decade beginning 2020
expenditures really start to accelerate
and then they accelerate further in the
year 2030 the bottom line is that
Medicare spending is unsustainable so if
you look at the overall picture we have
very high cost rapidly growing costs
we've got the problem of the uninsured
and the issues that raises but we have
an enormous federal health care deficit
that is in essence unsustainable now
what can we what can we do about it well
what drives the problem I'm going to
emphasize one main facet of the problem
and one main facet of the problem is in
the United States we have evolved the
system where there is too much public
and private insurance now in many
audiences people would begin to walk out
or hoechlin
when I say that too much insurance are
you out of your mind are you some sort
of right-wing wacko but the answer the
truth is we have too much of the wrong
kinds of insurance if you took a hundred
healthcare economists and asked them and
they weren't in some of them would admit
it publicly they would all admit it
privately probably ninety of those
economists would definitely say we have
too much of the wrong kind of insurance
maybe more than 90 and what is this
involved the type of insurance we have
gives rise to too much utilization of
expensive low valued care and it also
leads to inadequate incentives for
strong managed care and delivery system
reforms now people hate the idea of
managed care where physicians play a
significant role in determining what
types of care you may actually get when
people get to choose being in that
system it's a different matter my point
here though is the way we the way we
finance insurance has discouraged
incentives for people to voluntarily
choose programs that would reduce the
consumption of low valued care so how do
we get too much insurance of the wrong
type there are three big subsidies
subsidy number one is the tax subsidy to
employer-sponsored health insurance talk
about more about that in a minute tech
subsidy number two is the
intergenerational subsidy to Medicare
and indirectly to supplemental coverage
subsidy number three is the intra
generational subsidy to Medicaid I have
Medicaid is very problematic I have less
issues with Medicaid than I do with
Medicare but we basically have these
three parts of the puzzle we may find it
extraordinarily difficult to deal with
the second part the Medicare Part
something will have to be done one of my
messages that we don't want to screw up
the first part the private market for
the under age 65 population because of
the problems we may face with the second
part next slide please here's a little
evidence of the growth of insurance in
the United States this gives
out-of-pocket expenditures as a percent
of total healthcare expenditures and
we're now down to about eleven percent
its projected to go down or 10
nine percent over the next ten years so
the amount of expenditures that are
ensure just one minus this this
proportion now look we've obviously seen
a gradual long-term increase in the
amount of expenditures that are insured
and when you think of this this includes
all the uninsured people in the medical
care they get so the amount of uninsured
care here is what people are paying and
deductibles and copays and what people
pay that don't have insurance so you can
see that almost ninety cents on the
dollar is insured even when we have 50
million uninsured next slide please this
gives a comparison across countries the
bluest the light blue bar is the
percentage of total health expenditures
financed by basically private insurance
the white would be government insurance
and you can't see the white I didn't
want to put that in there and the dark
is private out-of-pocket spending and
there's a lot on this slide but the
thrust of this is if you look at
percentages and there might be
complaints about looking at percentages
if you looked at percentages the United
States we we have as out-of-pocket
expenditures a relatively low amount
compared to other countries with much
more government involvement in their
system my point here is a simple one is
that even with our uninsured problem we
are very heavily insured in the United
States next slide please SLE indicated
the ppaca is going to make matters worse
we're going to expand the number of
insured we're going to prescribe the
types of coverage to a great extent that
newly insured and currently insured
people get we are going to expand
utilization of care and necessarily
expand utilization of some very low
value care we're going to help subsidize
low income people not only with what
they purchase but we're going to make it
so they have very low co-payments that
encourages the consumption of good
health care it encourages the
consumption of low valued health care
the law does include an excise tax to
kick in in 2018 on high-cost tells plans
a 40-percent to be paid by the insurer
the employer that does
address the problem of incentives that
many people have wanted to have a dress
but it does it in a somewhat peculiar
way and in general that provision I
would regard is a little bit too little
a little bit too late and a little bit
too opaque as Sally mentioned we will
get adverse selection and health
insurance markets as when people face
premiums they'll vary only in a three to
one range by age the young and the
healthy are going to have some tendency
not to comply with the mandate to take
the fine the older and the sick will
tend to move into the insurance without
any exclusions which will drive up costs
the bill also will be stabilized
individual and small-group health
insurance markets I assure you I've
started to read the regs that have come
out the mandates and the insurance
requirements will involve an enormous
amount of red tape and enormous
bureaucracy and there's going to be more
to come because of price controls that
are already built into the system on
health insurance and those that are
being implemented including specified
statutory minimums on the amount of
premiums that must go towards medical
expenses next please just quickly on
this some background information about
studies that have projected what would
happen to health insurance premiums and
the answer is generally yes health
insurance premiums will go up under the
new law next slide please with regard to
Medicare the law is Sally indicated is
projected to cut about five billion
dollars or I can't even get the numbers
five hundred billion dollars out of
Medicare spending over two years this is
going to have a number of responses that
are going to be difficult for hospitals
richard foster the CMS actuary chief
says these cuts are not going to be
sustainable more people are going to go
into the traditional Medicare program as
Medicare Advantage plans get squeezed at
the end of the day we're going to have a
hard time making Zen beats and there
probably will be further restrictions on
care next slide please part of what went
on during the health care reform debate
was the total demonization of private
health insurers private health insurers
are hard to love insurance companies are
hard to love but what went on during the
health care reform me was really beyond
the pale it can only be understood in
the context of a hard core group of
liberals who want single pay in the
United States they want a public option
that is the option the only choice for
everyone ultimately they are enamored
with that model they wanted a public
insurance company or a public option to
be included in the bill and it was very
important in order to do that to
basically make the case that the private
sector was totally dysfunctional and
broken and what happened in that part of
the debate is real problems in private
health insurance were amplified
thousands of percents beyond the nature
of the problem and I've written a lot
about this and could provide you with
information but the misinformation was
really profound and now we've set up an
environment with Katherine Sebelius
where we are starting to put the
stranglehold on insurance companies as
we move into 2014 and we will be hearing
again about a possible public option
next slide please in fact let's next
next let's get this stuff next I like
this next my students would love it if I
did this next okay what you what you
missed were some information about what
health insurance companies really make
in terms of profitability and the short
story is you can go back 20 or 30 years
health insurance companies at the end of
the day profit and nonprofit are
averaging in the neighborhood of 3% of
premiums actually go towards
profitability and overall only another
ten to twelve percent goes towards
administrative expense but I will move
on to my main charge I'm going to keep
things real simple which you appreciate
it in the interest of time I like that
five better than this one in the in the
interest of time I won't give much
detail on specifics overall what can we
do we can have more government to
control costs restrict access or we can
try to move towards a market-oriented
agenda the overall agenda should be to
encourage greater responsibility
and consumer sovereignty for medical
care so that those who are able and
that's a large proportion of the
population those who are able to vote
more attention to the cost of medical
care as well as the benefits now nobody
can get elected saying that it might
appear right you have to pay more
attention to the cost but it has to
happen we either have to pay more
attention to the cost as consumers or
people will pay attention to the cost
for us and that I think dachshund and
hospital should pay close attention to
having the government do it as well
there are three broad steps that can be
taken one step is to do nothing step
don't discourage the greater cost
sharing in the private sector that's
already taking place the second broad
step is to reduce the tax subsidy to
generous employer sponsored health
insurance and the third broad step is to
transform Medicare to promote choice and
responsibility I've got some slides that
I'm going to skip through to illustrate
what's going on in the private sector
but in the interest of time I'll just
say one response to growing health costs
has been for employers and individual
insurers to redesign plans to try to
control costs sometimes that means
making the employee contribute more
sometimes it means a higher deductible
sometimes it means higher co-payments
everyone knows this we've had a
tremendous growth in high deductible
health plans including those with
tax-favored health savings accounts
where people can put money into a
tax-sheltered accounts they get a
catastrophic insurance plan if they go
to the doctor and it's not covered under
the catastrophic plan they can use money
in their account but it's their money if
they don't use it on medical care it
accumulates on a tax-deferred basis
towards retirement next slide please go
through this one next next next next
thank you
Obamacare has provisions in it that can
chill these healthy changes one
provision it has is basically the
requirement that the policies that are
sold meet certain actuarial requirements
it's not clear yet whether high
deductible health plans will really be
able to meet those requirements so
there's some risk on that dimension
there's also a direct risk and that for
health plans to remain grandfathered and
for people to be able to keep the
insurance that they've got the health
plan can't change much and so for
example a health plan an employer-based
health plan would lose its grandfather
status if it increased the co-insurance
percentage on its plan even if it
increased it from twenty percent to
twenty one percent it would no longer be
grandfathered there are other things
that would affect grandfathering so
what's what's a little more in this big
agenda what can we do we can reduce the
tax incentive for workers especially
higher paid wants to be compensated with
general health ensure with generous
health insurance what does this do it'll
spur the growth of high deductible and
related plans will encourage more people
to choose plans with strong managed care
this will promote greater competition
among providers and it will stimulate an
avalanche of information to guide choice
I think we should also equalize the tax
treatment of individual employer
sponsored coverage that would have
beneficial effects but the main thing is
getting at the tax preference there are
lotsa means to do this senator McCain's
plan for refundable tax credits was a
good one I don't believe he ever
articulated how good it was or even
really articulated it next slide please
I'm gonna run over just one minute now
here is the tough one the other ones
talking fact it wasn't even in the
Republican pledge basically no one wants
to bring up this issue again about
reforming the tax code related to health
insurance but the next one is hiring
transforming Medicare Paul Ryan has put
out a document Congressman Paul Ryan
dealing with this and as a result he's
taken a lot of heat but will have to
address Medicare in a very fundamental
way for people that are say younger than
HP
and this is going to involve giving
seniors more choice having them have
more financial responsibility but
allowing them to choose plans that best
meet their needs with a hammer a heavy
government subsidy so those are the two
main prongs up my time is up there are
other things we can do to promote viable
competitive private health insurance
markets those include allowing people to
buy insurance across state lines and I
could talk about some of that if there
are questions
thank you Scott we have time for
questions and please we have the
microphone here good if you have a
question raise your hand we will try to
get to you address your question to who
which of the panelists you think would
best be able to answer first of all I
want to thank the panel this is probably
one of the best presentations I have
ever seen on health care thank you all
my question is really directed primarily
to Thomas but actually for the entire
panel I had a student in New England I'm
dr. Margaret Britt and I had the
privilege of teaching Barbara's she was
one of the first sales executives for
glaxo smith welcome in New England and
this woman really educated me about the
innovation and the research and
development to get drugs to market under
Obamacare Thomas what do you see how can
we really get back our innovative
capacity it's critical in this area
because we lead the world yeah this on
yep there's two aspects of this one is
health care spending most health
economists I think agree not because
evidence is great more by Fiat that
technological change is really what's
making this sector grow now that's not a
bad thing necessarily I mean spending
increases are great if the benefits
offset the increased costs so presumably
the health benefits in this case we
would be concerned with the studies that
been done on that topic universally show
that we get more in health than we spend
any intervention across the board I
would look at in healthcare pretty much
so that doesn't mean that we can't have
more efficient care etcetera
but it does mean that the benefits in
terms of health promotion are larger
than what we're spending so that we can
do better but it's not a bad thing in
some sense that spending has gone up
it's completely rational to try to
extend life which is what most people
value more than anything and in fact
economists have done studies showing
that the last century the value of
longevity going from 48 years of living
to 78 years of living is equally
valuable to all economic growth that
occurred during that century so we like
life a lot and we like being healthy a
lot so it doesn't it's not necessarily
so bad getting more to your question how
do we sustain that innovation in face of
what's going on us is really the engine
right now like I said a world economic
progress in in medical products if the
US were to go and the directors two
things going on unfortunately in the
u.s. one is the benefits of rd for
innovators is going to be going down
with new health care reform the second
aspect is that the cost of R&D is going
to go up because the FDA is being much
more stringent and careful in what
they're approving and that delays delays
darn the pipeline and makes it much
closer to bring things to market that
has in general obviously negative
effects on innovation we have seen in
the u.s. a Productivity slow down
dramatic productivity slowdown in terms
of the new products being approved by
FDA the last 30 years is going on
quickly so I'm pretty pessimistic if
we're going to path we're going we're
going to we're kind of converging to a
European system and the history from
Europe is very very clear the history
from Europe is is that things get
introduced much later their people don't
innovate for Europe anymore about
two-thirds of innovation I moved from
Europe over to the US in the last 20
years that's an enormous shift in
and where innovation takes place so by
basically focusing on making things less
expensive or affordable like I said
that's a conflict between doing that
it's great if we take the number of
products or things we can do is given
but it's extremely damaging if we think
about the new things that going to be
developed for me and my kids or other
people in the future to come these
questions yep I'm sorry I just gonna add
one thing that you know the this FDA
panel a couple of weeks ago said that
avastin the drug which is net of
off-label use for breast cancer is too
expensive and it should be withdrawn
from from the list and I think it's very
important I had a lot of emails when I
wrote about this from patients who had
survived longer because of avastin I
guess the FDA full FDA is going to make
a decision in December about whether
this can continue on on their list and
it's very it is very expensive but when
it's your life I mean it's very very
important to you and I see under
Obamacare there will be a lot more
control just like nice and the UK has
over over medical decisions for people i
think it's it's very frightening this
questions for professor Harrington I
used to be a graduate research assistant
and research and sponsored programs at a
pretty major university and also
upgraded evaluated federal grant
proposals for teaching American history
programs and I was always frustrated and
astounded at the percentage of indirect
costs that were no it's already a
taxpayer funded institution and yet the
university wants twenty to thirty
percent in indirect costs if I
understood you correctly said ten
percent of health care premiums go
towards administrative fees what is the
projected percentage of those
administrative fees under Obamacare
okay technical difficulties with me
today that isn't that as an excellent
question what I can tell you is that the
CBL came up with another 140 billion or
so dollars after the bill was passed
that they said well this will involve
administration but it wasn't directly
part of the bill I don't have a percent
or numbers kind of in aggregate I read
the other day its projected that there
will be 38 billion dollars in
expenditures to set up exchanges and run
the health insurance exchanges in the
various states over 10 years there will
be enormous expenditures associated with
implementing the various trial programs
accountable care organizations the
patient-centered outcomes Research
Association and the like so the problem
here of course is you can end up with
relatively small expenses towards
administration what they end up
producing very very large amounts of
money when you're dealing with a beast
this big and your main point is that
there will be a large bureaucratic cost
to all this and there certainly will be
it will be dwarfed by the impacts on the
value that people may be able to get and
there and the value they drive from the
system but it will be very costly not on
that if I can get the microphone okay
during the campaign this was sort of
promoted as what we have studies is
showing that CMS expenditure running the
system is about four percent of you know
spending that they control compared to
the twelve percent so this was actually
one of the key pillars during the
campaign look we can cut eight percent
of healthcare spending right there by by
making it public and so my response why
it stopped at healthcare why don't we
just have the whole economy and the
government if it's run more efficiently
the the the problem with that argument
is
is-is-is several aspect one is just the
accounting that they're doing a share of
post 65 spending so it's not that the
administrative costs are lowest is that
what you're dividing by is bigger that
seniors people senior seniors are much
higher health care spending than the
private sector so it's just an
accounting issue so if you look at per
enrollee costs essentially as opposed to
as a share of spending per person
they're very similar in the private
sector and in the public sector the
second issue which I have argued is that
Medicare administrative costs are too
low what do I mean by that well the
private sector has a lot of
administrative costs in controlling
spending I'm utilization review making
sure that the claims get don't get paid
for unnecessary care so if you look at
medicare it's estimated about ten to
fifteen percent of medicare is fraud
that could be eliminated by higher
administrative costs that kind of fraud
would never occur in the private sector
presumably and there's a whole business
in Florida set up to take advantage of
Medicare where you have were you selling
illegal lists of seniors and in ordering
wheelchairs to get your business going
that could never occur in the private
sector and the reason it could not occur
in the private sector because there's
much more stringent controlled of what
gets paid out to whom for what purpose
so that administrative cost is adding to
the efficiency of the private sector but
it looks like it's inefficient so I
think on there's two aspects of this one
is just accounting of what you're
measuring is done wrong and the second
is that a health care plan should
essentially monitor costs a lot more
than what Medicare does the president in
many of his 5858 speeches said it was
about five hundred billion dollars worth
of fraud and abuse in Medicare and
Medicaid and my point I kept saying well
then you're trying to take the American
people to more government involvement
when the fraud and abuse are in the
government sector and you know I just I
thought it was interesting that he
didn't kind of pick up on that
the other point is as Thomas said I mean
Medicare at three to four percent admin
costs really you know their role is to
pay out claims and they actually farm
that out too wellpoint so but insurers
have to not have fraud and abuse they
have to build networks they have to pay
claims they have to collect premiums say
so you're not comparing apples to apples
when when you hear this constant
statistic I'd like to thank the panel
and I want to address my question to the
whole panel I think you did a great job
in talking about health care as an
economic issue but I wondered if you
could put it in the context of health
care as a health issue in particular you
showed the statistics got at a belief of
the cost the u.s. is spending more per
person than any other country but you
didn't show the outcomes and the outcome
suggests that the u.s. is not the best
health care system and in fact the
outcomes for longevity for infant
mortality rate for life quality of life
are not the best in the US and so we
have to ask even a bigger question of
what else is wrong with health care so
it seems to me that outcomes is an
important part of the equation that was
missed a second question someone
mentioned the acute care that's
available for people that are uninsured
but there's no chemotherapy and there's
no prenatal care available at emergency
rooms and so as a result this aspect of
health care is not really accessible to
people that don't have insurance the
third point is that you talked about the
European system but as nearly as I can
tell there is no European system there
is a French system which is very
different than a German system which is
very different than British and Swiss
and in fact he re-wrote a really
brilliant book called the healing of
America where he talks about the
different characteristics of these
different systems and I wonder if anyone
has seriously looked at the economics
from the point of view of the German or
French system not just the English or
Canadian thanks
I can comment on a couple of those one
concerns the outcomes another common
discussion we in the US doesn't mean we
don't live a lot longer than other
countries that's the first thing that
people point out health economy is kind
of dismissed that argument in the sense
that this health care is there is one
out of several inputs that affects your
health and and there's many other things
that drive our jeopardy or quality of
life than health care in fact health
care probably has minor effects on your
overall quality of life for longevity
we're much more beasts in the u.s. we
have a much higher violence mortality or
mortality from violence than other
countries particularly in the
african-american community that do
affect health outcome has nothing to do
with health care quality of care is
clearly the best in the US everyone
travels here when they won't care if you
can't afford it obviously that's an
issue so the you don't see poor
individuals from other countries coming
but you do see rich individuals coming
we have done a study currently doing a
study we will look at oncology care
across european countries in the US and
there's a significant difference in how
much longer people live in the u.s.
conditional a given stage and diagonal
diagnosis across six types of cancers so
we are spending more but at least it
oncology that study shows that we are
getting a lot more for our money the the
second issue of Europeans are not all
alike I I've been an advisor to the UK
system also currently getting them all
with the German and also have talked to
the French government and they are
different but they have one single a
common theme which is that there's a
single buyer and namely the government
and that tends to in most markets not
unique to health care and there's a lot
of evidence of that presumably when
you're single by you can command lower
system if there's a lot of other buyers
out there and that is the most important
aspect I think of government care that
they can press down prices below which
it makes it beneficial to innovate and
that has clearly been the experience
across you is across the European
countries and compared to the u.s.
talked about life expectancy a new who
often you know they bring out these
studies saying the United States ranks
39th after Morocco in Costa Rica and
Cuba well you know you have he made the
point it's true when you take out at a
card s gun killings obesity actually the
US does ranked number one on the inch
and the issue of infant mortality the
gal that was head of the CBO under under
Bush one she is a professor and she and
her husband did some some work and
showed a lot of countries don't count a
birth as live unless it is a certain
weight and a certain length the United
States has a very top neonatal care and
so we count those as live births even if
these high-risk babies pass away later
they wouldn't be live births and
therefore deaths in the in other
countries so you have to be careful
about how do you define the issue of
infant mortality I'm you know being
Canadian a gal in Calgary Alberta in
2008 was expecting identical quads there
wasn't a single neonatal unit in Calgary
in Alberta anywhere in Canada where she
could have those quads delivered she was
flown to Great Falls Montana a city of
55,000 where her quads were successfully
delivered and she went back and she said
thank goodness for that escape valve you
know I when the president says we have
too many MRI machines too many neonatal
units well for this gal it was important
and if the market is working if there is
no need for that it would go out of
business so that's an important point
and the second thing is on the cancer
survival rates even the work that's been
done already published in Lancet
Oncology the British Medical Journal the
survival rates for 13 of the 16 most
common cancer rates five years out the
United States does ranked number one in
breast cancer prostate cancer colon
cancers
survival's so that is a very important
point and in European countries I've
done work on Germany and France and
Thomas is right the issue is all of
those countries are facing severe cost
issues and they're putting more and more
control moving people more and more into
government-run health maintenance
organizations in America we tried the
HMO example it was popular costs for
going down but once people realize they
had to go to a gatekeeper they couldn't
call up their OBGYN there was a huge
rebellion against HMOs so we have to be
very very careful let me address just
another fast or the question the safety
net has gaps I've asked physicians on
numerous occasions I've said but what
happens if someone has cancer and needs
chemo I'm usually told that there is an
informal mechanism that will allow the
person to be directed either to a clinic
or a charity care environment where they
will get the treatment does that a
perfect system does it cover everybody
know but I think we underestimate the
extent to which those types of things
that go beyond emergency care are
provided on a charitable or otherwise
free basis if people don't spend down
and qualify for the public safety net
the other thing I'd like to add to that
is the conservative market Orion does
not rule out increase subsidies for
people to be able to buy insurance in
fact I think that's a fundamental part
of the platform the key issue is how do
you design the subsidies in an efficient
way I think what's happening with health
care reform the mandate and the
structure of subsidies in the great deal
of government prescription of what will
be provided in insurance markets is not
the way to go that we could come up with
something where we could target
subsidies that would help people buy
insurance without a mandate and and
undertake another a variety of changes
that would make things better and reduce
the types of problems that you suggest
without going down the route that we're
going five more minutes so I think we
have time for one more question
thank you I'm originally from Britain so
I've lived under that system but I was
very healthy when they live there so we
never even really thought about going to
the doctor very often but you were
allowed can you believe it allowed to
carry private insurance so when my
mother had hip problems she went to the
doctor and he said we'll see you in a
week privately or two years though I
know you can't really walk but we'll see
you in two years with the other system
the public system you know now my
question is are the lads and ladies in
Washington going to live under this plan
is Hollywood going to live under this
plan what what are they going to be
doing they're not going to be in with a
riff raff so could you ask
well of course people in in Congress and
people that work for the federal
government are covered by the federal
employees health benefit plan and it's
interesting it's run by the Office of
Personnel Management there's not a
single government-run insurance plan
within the FEHBP so so that's very
interesting the other point I was gonna
say is that when Canada started taking
over their health care system when they
went to Britain to say to politicians
what are the good things and the bad
things that the British authorities said
this started in 47 the National Health
Service the big mistake we made was
allowing private health insurance to run
parallel to the National Health Service
so when Canada wrote the Canada Health
Act they didn't allow private health
insurance to run parallel now of course
Canada realizes with the long waiting
lists and the upset that they are
looking to privatize parts of the system
and in fact in Quebec in 2005 the
Supreme Court ruled that the ban on
private health insurance and private
coverage was illegal because Quebecers
were not entitled to security the person
because of the long waits
well thank you so much this has been
just a fantastic panel and I will
explain to the audience that we always
have lots more information on these
panels than we can ever get to in 20
minutes per presenter so we will
certainly make available on our website
at hillsdale edu and then just cert do a
search on that side in its free market
for them but i'd like to have scotts a
powerpoint to post our faculty always
want those and any others we can get
from these panelists we have a
tremendous amount of knowledge and I
thank you for that today we'll get those
powerpoints up in a few days and we are
going to have a break and it will be a
30 minute break so please refresh
yourselves and be back in 30 minutes and
have one small announcement if Jonathan
Andreas is in this room please come down
and see me and we'll be back in 30
minutes thank you
you